Matthew Perry rest in peace uh he's
going around the internet in all of
these clips of him and some of his final
days and years and there's one clip
that's particularly poignant where
Matthew Perry is discussing what he
thinks about God I was put on a thing
called an emo machine which you having
read the book you would know what that
is but it's a it's no I did I took notes
I underlined it say oh no I believe you
um but they call that a Mary that's what
they do when they put you on an emo
machine when it's a Hail Mary and five
people were on ECMO that night the other
four died and and I somehow made it well
um what God is a is a fan yeah I mean I
know you're feeling about that um but I
I well I know I'm a fan maybe I'm okay I
I know that uh once you've referred to
it as a force and you know it I believe
I believe that I believe believe that a
higher power there is higher power I
believe I've had a very close
relationship with him that's helped me a
lot and somebody's on your side yeah
this is really nice some people are
going to recoil just a little bit from
Matthew Perry using this vague language
of a higher power but first of all he's
talking to Bill Maher who's one of the
most famous atheists in the country so I
think he's just trying to get through to
him a little bit it's not a debate that
they're having he's just trying to
convey this year and then even when he
says look you've talked about like a
force well yeah that's kind of what I
believe in and I think I have a close
relationship with him so there you see
he tips his hand he's not talking about
some abstract Force he's talking about a
personal God and he says I think I have
a close relationship with him and that
has helped me a
lot and I I don't doubt
him I didn't read Matthew Perry's book
Drew read it and after he read it he
called me or I saw him he said he was
like you got to read Matthew Perry's
book I saidwhat
why he said it's really poignant it's
it's it's just it's so Illuminating and
he he described a scene in Perry's life
from the book was the first time Perry
prayed he apparently said please God
make me famous you can do anything you
want to me just make me
famous and three weeks later the guy
gets cast in friends one of the biggest
TV shows of all
time and got God did not forget about
it this reminds me of a famous verse of
scripture which is ask and it shall be
given to
you which is why you've got to be
careful of what you ask for
because when we make an idol out of
something and we desire that thing above
all things we get it and and then we're
the dog that caught the car and
sometimes that thing is not for our
flourishing it's not been in our best
interest and sometimes that thing can
destroy us that happens all the time
with Fame in Hollywood I'm not sure that
I can name I know a lot of very
successful actors because I lived in La
for a long time and been around Show
Business a little bit
and I don't know that I could name a
single happy one may maybe a handful of
exceptions
maybe I'm talking successful guys I'm
not talking about unsuccessful guys
you've got to be very very careful for
what you wish for there been things that
I've desired in life that I haven't
gotten that I was really upset about
that I didn't get and then in retrospect
I think oh that would have ruined my
life had I gotten that my life is so
much better now because God had a better
plan than I did and so Matthew Perry
said apparently in some of his final
days he said I know that when I die I'm
just going to be remembered as Chandler
being from friends but I hope I'm
remembered for more than that and just
how I've tried to help people and helped
addicts and things like that and
uh that might be true he he probably
won't he'll he'll be remembered as
Chandler Bing but he might be remembered
for some of these
poignant things I mean the fact that his
book was such a big hit and it was so
helpful and it it came out just shortly
before he died uh that's good and it's a
consolation that that the guy had a
relationship with God you know we hope
that everyone comes into the fullness of
truth but any little step in the right
direction is hopeful and it's why
especially troubled people can be uh
great guides for the rest of us because
we we see the local consequences of vice
and sin they know it better than anybody
you know and and so they're they're
often the ones who are some of the best
evangelist so anyway worth worth praying
for Matthew Perry and a really
uh poignant end to an unexpected end to
a career that's basically known for some
catchphrases from a '90s sitcom now
speaking of things that uh really matter
you know we all want to store our gold
up in heaven um but we have to take care
of the body and things while we're here
on this Earth and so so when you want
gold here on Earth you got to check out
Birch gold right now text nolles to 998
9898 yet again we are facing the threat
of a government shutdown later this
month and yet again the administration
will ultimately deal with it the same
way they always do with more spending
more spending equals a lower value of
the dollar protect your savings by
diversifying your savings into gold with
the help of the Birch gold group here's
the best part when you open a gold Ira
with Birch gold for every $10,000 you
spend by December 22nd Birch gold will
send you a free gold bar just text
nolles kwes to 98 9898 to claim
eligibility before Black Friday Birch
gold can even help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in gold
for no money out of pocket and you still
get the free gold bars with an A+ rating
with a Better Business Bureau and
thousands of satisfied customers you can
count on Birch gold to help you navigate
transitioning and existing Ira or 401K
into an IRA in Gold don't let your
savings become a victim of the further
devaluation of the dollar through more
spending text NS canes to 98 9898 to
receive a free info kit on gold and
claim your eligibility before Black
Friday to receive free gold bars on your
qualifying purchase that is nolles kws
to 9898 98 Cornell just issued an
emergency alert for uh Jewish students
so uh they issued this alert Cornell
Hillel a Jewish Center says they're
aware of a threatening statement that
was directed toward the building at 104
West which houses the University kosher
and Multicultural dining hall as well as
more generally toward Jewish students
faculty and staff the Cornell University
Administration has been made aware of
the concerning language and the Cornell
Police Department is monitoring the
situation and is on site with additional
security as a precaution at this time we
advise that students and staff avoid the
building out of an abundance of caution
we will continue to provide updates as
additional information becomes available
very bad stuff now part of this was made
online so it could be a
hoax I I'm not I don't think it's a hoax
of Jewish students saying this about
themselves I don't think so that has
happened that sort of thing has happened
often when there are anti-black
statements written on a wall or or uh
the white supremacist symbols or that
that has often been a hoax in recent
years especially in fact I document a
whole slew of them in my book speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
thank you same thing goes for anti-woman
you threatening what is called rape
culture statements those have often
proved to be hoaxes there haven't been a
ton in recent American memory of Jewish
students doing these things about
themselves and we've seen a huge spike
in anti-jewish attacks and rhetoric so I
I I think it could
be I don't think it would be them doing
it to themselves but I could see it
being sort of a hoax because it was
online people online make all sorts of
comments that that don't really have any
bearing in in reality but if I were the
Jewish students of Cornell I would I
would hunker down I would take it very
very
seriously the timing of this is a little
odd because I am going to Cornell on
Monday I was invited to speak at Cornell
a lot of the schools this semester some
of which are very prominent schools have
been dragging out the contracts because
the students want me to come but the
administrations don't want me to come uh
so we haven't announced a lot of my
speaking tour this semester this one
we're announcing last minute but it's
been the works for a while that I'll be
going to Cornell and I don't know what
it is I keep going to these schools when
the terrorists show up so I was at
Pittsburgh University of Pitts last
semester and I showed up when antifa was
threatening to harm all sorts of people
and burn me an effigy on the street and
threw an explosive at the building right
as I went to walk on stage and and now
I'm showing up to Cornell days after
they're threatening to kill the Jews so
I guess that I guess that'll help
formform my talk initially I was
thinking about speaking on I don't know
some of the the false premises of
Enlightenment
liberalism could talk about the itical
philosophy of dooo Cortez I find that
interesting but I guess now I'll have to
narrow it down
to actually you shouldn't kill all the
Jews that would be that's one potential
title maybe um you don't in fact have to
hand it to Hamas maybe that that's a
good title uh I don't know I but but
I've got my work cut out for me and
anyway if you're around Ithaca next
Monday I will see you there man that was
a good clip huh now you got to ring the
bell you got to subscribe to the Michael
NS YouTube channel we'll see you next
time